Let me remind you that the,
uh,
the Spartans ever since their victory
and the Peloponnesian war had been,
uh,
attempting to extend their head Gemini
at first all the way over into Asia.
And then when that was sorted,
they tried to do so on
the mainland of Greece.
And,
uh,
one consequence of their effort and the
failure to achieve in an easy way was
the restoration of Athens to a
primary position in the Greek world.
Again,
not as powerful as Sparta,
but once again an independent state
that was a capable of being a serious
opponent of the Spartans.
And today I wanna talk about the
emergence of a third great power in this
period,
which had never had a position,
I think of,
um,
something resembling equality with
the leading powers in the Greek world.
Although it had had periods
when it was very strong. Anyway,
teams is what I'm talking about now.
You start,
if you look at the situation in three
79 when the Spartans were in control of
thieves as a consequence of
the actions of a fever gas,
there was a spot in garrison there
in the city on its Acropolis.
There were spartan garrisons
in other towns in be Osha.
And that was probably as low a point for
the feed bins as they had experienced
since the four fifties when the
Athenians gained control of the Osha.
But starting with the
successful Sieben rebellion,
which overthrew the spartan
command of the city,
the Thebesians launched a period of growth
in power influence a wealth and even
to some degree extent,
which justifies a modern historians.
And speaking about a period,
perhaps beginning in three 71 and running
at least a decade to which they give
the name,
the Sieben hegemony.
And today I want to talk about how that
happened and how it sort of developed
and ended. Well, not, not
ended, not today. Yeah.
I guess I will be talking
about how in a day, right? Um,
the Spartans invaded after the
Athenian overthrow of spartan rule.
And in the first year,
the lead in that invasion
was given to, uh, uh, I,
the young king Cleon Burtis not to
adjust the layers and his failure to
undertake that command a exercise the
minds of ancient writers as well as modern
ones.
One answer whenever adjusts the latest
doesn't take command of an army,
which is following a policy that he likes.
People suggest that he might've been
physically incapable of doing it.
He was an old man and he was,
he had been injured.
And so there's a,
that's a plausible reason that any time,
and yet the ancient writers were persuaded
that there were times when he was
simply playing politics in
some complicated way and
choosing not to take the
command.
And this is one of those occasions when
they speculate that he was trying to get
clean on bridges,
engaged in this anti and policy,
which would provide for greater support
for that general [inaudible] in policy.
And that that's why he had worked it
so that [inaudible] has got to command.
We simply can't be sure about
what the truth of that is.
Clay Ombre does, however,
it did not a wage,
a very aggressive campaign and that a
first invasion of three 78 produced very,
very little. However,
subsequent Spartan Invasions.
Also,
even those led by just laze,
we're not successful.
The [inaudible] were able to
gradually to gather their strength to,
uh,
recover parts of,
be Osha and bring them under their power
and to drive the Spartans away without
yielding anything of importance.
One of the consequences, I'm talking
really about the years, three 88,
three three 73 77,
three 76 and into three 75.
One of the things that the, uh,
Steven's engaged in in this period,
and it's extremely important because it
provides the basis for the power that
they will develop was a
reconstruction of the B Ocean League.
The Thebans had commanded or led or
dominated the be ocean league before they
changed its constitution.
However, in these years,
in a way that was a rather important,
it w what the in word it
to simplify the matter,
the entire operation of the
Lee became more democratic.
They used to have the decisive bodies
that determine Sieben policy in the form
of four separate, um, councils,
which were sort of in direct
regimes that really made the policy,
the new constitution made the decisive
place really an assembly in which all the
representatives of the
urban cities came and, uh,
made policy in an assembly,
not in separate councils,
all of which could be more readily
controlled by oligarchic figures.
And,
uh,
the only thing is that the meetings of
the B Ocean League took place in thieves.
Now, not only did Thebes have a majority
of representatives in that league by,
or at least the largest number by
virtue of its size and its leading role,
but the fact that it all took place in
Thebes meant that there would be more
thebesians there.
And I'm Moore Stephens playing an
influential role in what was going on.
Nonetheless,
we shouldn't discount the truly
democratic nature of this regime.
It's a new thing. Be Osha and
Thebes used to be a bulwark of our,
of a oligarchy and it became
a remarkably democratic city.
And,
uh,
I think there's reason to take note of
the fact that this seemed to have had an
impact on thieves and be Osha much
like the one that Heraclitus praises so
highly, uh, back when
Athens became democratic,
when they threw out the tyrants and
established the Cli Senek regime,
Heraclitus says they
became better warriors,
they produced a better army.
They'd began to feeding their
enemies as they had not done before.
I think that is very clearly also what
happens in themes that we can't get away
from the fact that seems became a more
formidable military power thereafter.
Whether or not it's linked to
democracy is open to argument,
but I think there is a real argument
that would say it worked that way.
At least we don't know the
details of this very well,
but a very unusual thing
seems to have happened.
The Thebus ultimately were able to
increase the size of their army by using
farmers who would not ordinarily have
been able to afford hoplite equipment.
But somehow the state managed
to equip poorer farmers and to,
uh,
turn them into hoplites so that ultimately
the army that Thebes commanded when
you get down to the,
a years after the battle of Luke Tra
in which the Thebans and their friends
defeated the Spartans,
you will see that, uh,
really a huge army by Greek standards
goes marching into the Peloponnesus of
which a large proportion was this Steven
hoplite group that was a much more
potent because of its size.
And it could be argued because of the
spirit of these new newly hoplite in the
Democrats, you might say, well,
as the Thebans were
developing this league,
they were also fighting the Spartans
and gradually driving the Spartans back.
For instance, the, uh, uh,
they destroyed the city of Plataea,
which was always on the side of the
enemies of thieves. In this case,
they were on the side of
the Spartans and, uh, uh,
it would take a while
before that was undone.
They also placed a number of
cities under thieving command.
They didn't need to do that for most
of the cities in be Osha because mostly
they were, they seem to be satisfied
and pleased to cooperate with the thing.
I why not?
I mean,
I should make the point clear as to
why they would be happy to do that.
When the Spartans invaded be Osha. They
didn't only beat up Thebes. In fact,
Thebes was less hurt than were the other
towns because seeds was further away
and better equipped to defend itself.
Every time the Spartans came in,
they ravage to be ocean countryside
and did harm to these be ocean town.
So it was thieves that was the defender,
the protector of the bee oceans against
the Spartans in this certainly gave them
popularity.
It helps explain why this new B ocean
confederation was so effective and so
loyal.
The Thebans,
we're doing a key job for be
Osha and to be oceans and this,
uh, meanwhile this new army
that was being put together,
I wasn't of course entirely new.
It's heart would have been the
old B ocean hoplite farmer, uh,
group. But it was added to and
it was given this new twist,
I think really a combination
twist of two kinds of, uh,
elements that explain
a kind of enthusiasm,
a kind of morale boost
that they had. One was, uh,
a greater sense of what
we would call nationalism.
It's obviously an acronystic
for the city states,
but we don't have a better word for it.
That is to say this constant warfare,
these constant attacks by the Spartans
culminating in this seizure of their city
against all,
uh,
custom against all law and very
unpleasant way and the support of these
oligarchs as against the common
people in the ordinary folks.
So that when the,
this new regime led,
I should point out by these
two extraordinary military
leaders Palapa das and
anonymous.
When these fellows also were
responsible for the liberation of feeds,
especially Palapa Daz and when they were
leading the fight for the defense of
Biasha,
all of that meant that there was a
growing feeling of we are be oceans,
we are together and the enemy is the
Spartans and we need to fight them,
uh, to with that. If you
throw in the feeling that, um,
democracy appears to
have in its first burst,
especially I should point out that,
uh,
the Athenian extraordinary success on
land occurs right after the democratic
revolution of Kleist and knees.
I don't say they become bad thereafter,
but they're never again
quite as extraordinary as a
land force as they are then.
And analogy that's often drawn is with
the armies of the French Revolution in
the 18th century,
which really were fantastically successful
right after the revolution began.
And they began enrolling
in deed conscripting great
numbers of people who would
never have been in the army before,
uh, on, in the name of the nation,
in the name of freedom, in the name
of all kinds of lovely things. Again,
that's often neglected that the French
already had a terrific army before that
happened and they had wonderful officers
and generals and was skilled in the art
of war.
So it was a kind of a best of all
worlds where they had a solid base for
military superiority to which
was added this great group.
There's great business of numbers
and the zeal that went with it,
something like that I believe is going
on here in the three seventies to help
explain what's happening to the,
what becomes is enormously powerful
and successful theme and army.
Um,
the fighting goes on the feed bins,
you remembered joined with the Athenians
against the Spartans back at the time
of the foundation of the Second Athenian
confederacy and three 77 and they do
work together for a time,
but it doesn't take very long for there
to grow up differences between the
Athenians and the be oceans.
They are,
if you look back at the whole history
more frequently enemies than they are
friends. They are longstanding
differences, suspicions,
attitudes that are not
entirely friendly and so on.
And as Stephen Power grows and as
the threat from Sparta diminishes,
the Athenians become less enthusiastic
about their alliance with thieves because
the Thebans are now emerging as a
contender for the leading position for
[inaudible] position in Greece.
So we will see the Athenians and
the FIBA gradually moving apart.
In the decade of the three seventies,
there was in three 75 a proposal for
peace to be established in the warring
Greek world.
It was apparently there's some
difference of opinion among our sources.
But one thing that seems clear,
the King of Persia was in favor of it.
The ancient writers explain
his reason for doing that,
for being interested in
having that happen. Uh,
because he had other wars to
fight as so often was the case.
There was a rebellion in Egypt,
which was always a serious menace.
So he wanted peace so that he could hire
Greek mercenaries to fight in his army.
Perhaps that wasn't the only
reason that the great king had. Um,
he must have been worried at the growth
of Athenian power and influence at sea,
which was continuing
throughout this period.
The second Athenian Confederacy.
Never had the power and the extent that
the great empire had had in the fifth
century,
but it,
it was scary from the standpoint of the
great king and so he might very well
have wanted to restore peace to Greece
as a way of stopping excuses for further
expansion on the part of the Athenians.
On the other hand,
the Athenians were not unhappy to make
peace as an opportunity to consolidate
the gains that they had had and because
that would put a stop to what I think
was beginning to worry them.
The expansion of Thebes and mind you,
they're still worried.
Number one about Sparta in three 75
Spartans haven't been defeated by anybody.
That's still the most serious power and
there's still the power that stands for
Persian,
a power in the Greek world,
but things have become more complicated
as thieves as emerged on the scene.
Well,
the ancient right,
a diet doors especially
speaks of an event.
Well,
let me describe the event.
He says that when it was time
to sign this common piece,
maybe I just want to say a word about that
too. The Greek words for common piece,
our coin ne a rain a,
it is a term that comes up again and
again in the fourth century in attempting
to bring a peace agreements among the
Greek states. It's, it's a new thing.
As you know,
piece in the past usually took the form
of the swearing of odes to accept a
peace treaty on very specific terms
between competence in that war.
The coin, a Renae concept has a more
modern ring to it and it's, it's,
uh,
seems to have the idea that there should
be a common peace among all the Greeks
and that the signatories
should be responsible for
upholding that common piece.
Um,
it's a very interesting idea and it
sparked enormous interest in scholars,
I think,
especially after the first world war
when all of the helpful talk about the
League of Nations and [inaudible] picture
of perpetual peace and all of that
stuff was flying around
in certain circles.
So people hope to see in the coin a rainy,
this might have been a,
uh, a preliminary sign of
that same kind of idea,
but it didn't work any better in the
ancient world than it has worked in the,
uh,
in the modern world.
To get back to the first suggestion
in three 75 about having such a thing,
these states were agreed to do it.
And then in the trouble came when thieves
insisted that just as the Spartans
could sign on behalf of all of their
allies for the Peloponnesian League,
the Thebans wanted the right to sign for
all of their B ocean allies on behalf
of the ocean leak.
It would have been the de
facto recognition of the
ocean league with thieves as
its leader.
Uh,
this is really what happens if you put
your minds back to four 45 in the 30
years piece that concluded what we call
the first Peloponnesian war. When the A,
a spartan is allow the Athenians to sign
and speak for all the members of its
league. They were giving de facto
recognition and regarding the Greeks,
the Athenians as their equals.
This was something that the Spartans,
no doubt a lid chiefly in this view,
by adjust the latest, they were not
going to let the feed bins do it.
In fact,
we are told in a very bold action adjusts
to lay is struck the feed bins from
the lists.
The list of those who had taken her word
would take part in the piece because
they insisted on this cloth.
Now there's a problem about this.
The same story almost identically is
told in three 71 when we come to the
attempt at another coin, a rainy, uh, to,
to bring peace to the general Greek world.
The whole story is told in this pretty
much the same way and the upshot of the
one in three 71 will be the
great battle of loop truck.
This has led some scholars
to say diet doors.
Who is the source of these
tales simply has screwed up.
It's got it wrong.
This is what they call a doublet.
Somehow he projected backwards.
An event that really happened in
[inaudible] 71 and has it happened twice?
I'm very,
very suspicious about modern historians
who were prepared to rip up pieces of
ancient historians because we know better
and it just doesn't make any sense as
the argument. The truth is, I can see
no reason why they shouldn't have twice.
Certainly adjust. Uh, what's his name, uh,
at Pamet on this would
have insisted on that.
Certainly the Spartans would
have objected to it. Uh,
the actions that go with it strike me
as being perfectly okay in three 75 and
win four years later.
A similar circumstance emerges.
Why shouldn't the same thing happened
again, I haven't really looked into this,
but I can imagine if you look through
the whole Cold War history, uh,
I'm sure you'll find many things that
are happening over and over again and
exactly the same way because the
circumstances haven't changed.
So with my characteristic Gullibility,
I believe in the story as
it is told in three 75,
well fighting resumed since the
piece really didn't hold and the,
uh,
the Thebans continue and the be oceans
in general continue to successfully fight
off the Spartans. I should have
mentioned in the course of this fighting.
Soon after the uh,
treaty,
there's an amazing occasion which
has Harbinger's for the future.
A Spartan army is
marching in one direction.
A theme and army is marching
in another direction.
The Spartans out number. The
theme runs very greatly. In fact,
the Thevenin whole Sieben force is simply
the 300 men who had been formed pretty
recently into a special elite
fighting corps called the sacred band.
They're special quality was that in
addition to being excellent warriors and a
trained specially for their job,
they were a homosexual lovers who stood
and fought right next to each other.
This was a just carrying
forward the principle that
the Spartans had used in one
way and another, and it turned
out to be equally successful.
This sacred man was a tremendous fighting
force and will play a critical role in
the important battle of Luke Tra.
Anyway,
they managed to defeat in hoplite battle
a spartan forest that is greater than
they are. It's not a real hundred
percent happy hoplite battle.
The numbers.
There are only 300 feed bins.
Even as about a thousand a Spartans.
It's the way of battle is fought,
is not traditional and typical.
It's a little peculiar.
So you really can't regard
it as the decisive time.
Somebody beat a spartan hoplite Phalanx
and battle that we'll have to wait till
Luke trip. On the other hand, it,
the evidence of the ancients is that
it really impressed the Greek world in
general.
Even this form of a victory over a
spartan hoplites was unprecedented and it
really,
I think a kind of shook some people in
terms of their confidence at the Spartans
would always win a battle like that.
So the fighting goes on on all the
fronts that I have mentioned to you until
finally we get down to three 71 and
in three 71 the same thing happens.
There is a pressure from the
Persians for a general piece.
The Athenians are not against that idea,
uh,
but the same tale I told you last time,
there's no question that had happened
that Luke Trin, nobody doubts that.
And the result was a renewal of the
war with the Spartans taking the lead
aggressively moving into be Osha
as they had done every time before.
I think it's very worth mentioning that
we don't have any case up to now up to
three 71 in which to be oceans and
their friends and allies marching to the
Peloponnesus. All the attacking has
been by the Spartans into the Osha,
which means these wars have
always been costly to be Osha,
but not to Sparta.
And we'll see that the,
one of the things that [inaudible] does,
wants to do when he can is to,
um,
reverse that situation.
So this brings us to
the battle of Luke Tra.
Luke Tra is a town in
southwestern be Osha,
the two armies march towards each other
and there's a lot of maneuvering this
way in that way.
But finally they come on to
this rather small field. If you,
uh,
you can go there today and look at it,
it's really pretty easy to s to place
the ancient story into the modern,
uh, geography. Uh, each,
there's a plane between two hills,
went to the south and one to the north.
The ocean army took up its
position on the northern hill.
The Spartans took up there is on
the southern hill. Uh, and then, uh,
finally when the day life came,
they moved forward and fought each
other in this field, which is sort of,
it's,
it's plenty big enough for any kind of
hoplite battle that you want to have.
But some scholars have wanted to make a,
to explain the battle in
terms of a limited space,
but I think that really isn't an issue.
This is a sort of a typical spark
as typical hoplite battle field.
So can we Burdis marches on themes again,
it's not adjust the,
and I mean,
this looks like the culmination of adjusts
the laces. Antifreeze urban policy.
He's not there again, the ancient
writers and modern scholars, uh,
wonder why he wasn't there. I'm
prepared to take the simple minded view.
If he wasn't there,
he couldn't have been there.
He must've been out of action for physical
reasons because I can't imagine any
good reason why he wouldn't want to
be there for the payoff here. Anyway,
there was something in the neighborhood
of 10,000 Spartan hoplites and maybe a
thousand calvary.
And it's the sport that could
be ocean side is less clear,
maybe, maybe six, maybe
7,000 B ocean hoplites.
So they are outnumbered.
And I think that has a lot to do with
the tactics that he and on employs in
fighting this battle. It's a famous
battle. It's an important battle.
So I'll take a few moments to
talk about the battle itself.
Again,
this is a much debated,
it's not easy to know what's
going on or why it's going on,
but let's start with the important point
that the [inaudible] were outnumbered.
So it really was up to a Pam [inaudible]
to think of some way to overcome this
disadvantage.
Normal course of events,
six or 7,000 against 10,000
in irregular hoplite battle.
You can, the bookies would
take the game off the board.
I mean the, especially if they're
Spartans and palpitations,
the, uh, the bigger, the bigger
battalions are going to win.
So a feminine,
this comes up with certainly to s nobody
can deny that he came up with some kind
of plan.
What am I fussing about here?
Some scholars have wanted to
emphasize not the tactics of,
of Pamela Honda's,
but rather this superior fighting
qualities of this new fiebing democratic
national army. Well, I certainly
think that made a difference.
I give real credit to that element and
yet I can't escape thinking that there
really was a very tricky,
unusual strategy or tactics or operational
plan used by a patent on this that,
uh,
accounts in a considerable part for the
success of the seabirds in this battle.
He lined,
the normal way you line up is that the,
the sort of the leading forces on each
side take up the right wing of their
Phalanx.
That's the position of honor.
And that's where you try to beat the
other guy that has the consequences
incidentally, of meaning that the best
army doesn't fight against the best army.
In each case,
the best army is fighting against
a weaker portion of the enemy army.
That's not what Apam it on.
This wanted,
he put his fiebing forces with the 300 a
sacred band members at the front of it.
He, his, uh,
his own group was at the left side of
the B ocean line facing the Spartans
directly.
Now
the Spartans
had to realize when they saw what
was going on, oh, it, forgive me,
I forgot to tell you another
very important thing.
Instead of the usual depth
of the Phalanx, eight, 12,
maybe 16, ranks, uh,
Pam and don does loaded
his left wing 50 men deep.
And that is, it may be
precedented, but if so,
it's extremely rare in the past,
his idea apparently.
And then when he started for battle,
he took his left wing and moved it
over bleakly further to the left,
the plan being to flank the Spartans if
they could and come at them from their
vulnerable side and to, uh, uh,
do so in Turin,
tremendous strength.
I think the idea of the tremendous
strength in depth was to win on that side
quickly because he was weak
obviously on his right.
I suppose that the force
immediately after the Siemens,
what itself presents a problem because
if the feed bins went sharply to the left
on this occasion with their
deep powerful Phalanx,
the guys next to them probably would move
with them to some degree but not with
the same speed and not at the same
determination because their situation,
so there was the danger of there
being an opening right there.
That would have been very scary.
Apparently a Ananda monotonous
told the people on the right.
I would have thought everybody to the
right of his outfit to proceed only very
slowly.
If that's the case,
the Spartans then on the,
the pep help Aneesh and army on their
left would have had to take some time
before they could encounter the B ocean
army so that the first fighting would be
on the left.
We're at Pam on this,
wanted it and his hope was,
in a way,
this is a variety of
the marathon strategy.
You remember the big thing there was the,
the uh,
Siemens under mill tighties hoped to
win swiftly on the wings where they had
greater depths.
They knew they would lose in the middle.
They just hope they would lose slower
than they would win on the wings.
I think this is a version
of the same idea and so,
uh, on this and his, uh, uh,
block of feed bins goes to the left and
I would argue in the ancient sources
save is to, uh, swiftly as,
as Herata to set of the Athenians
that marathon draw boy on the run.
Well, I guess that means on
the truck. And so they were,
they wanted to get that fight going as
fast as they could and to win it as fast
as they could.
Well,
that's the essential idea that they
would win powerfully on the left and send
the Spartans into route and thereby
destroy their whole campaign.
Now we have to account for funny things
that happen apart from the Phalanx
before the battle is over,
both sides take their cavalry from the
usual position on the wings on the flanks
of the Phalanx.
Meant either to protect your
wings or to assault the other,
the enemy on his wing and move it to
the center of the battlefield where it
plays a role. And so the question
always is, what are they doing?
What's this all about? And one here,
I think one can only speculate,
uh,
surely it would have been a wise thing
for a Pam does to move his cavalry into
the center of the field in front of the
center of his line, not in front of him,
but in front of the guys to his right.
Because they too would have had an
effect of slowing down any spartan attack
where there was a vulnerability.
So if you take it from that point of view,
you could think to Spartans who
definitely moved there. Cavalry out front,
uh, did. So in order to
combat the fiebing cavalry,
that would be an explanation enough. But
some scholars make an argument and, uh,
there's some reason to
think they might be right.
That the Spartans seeing what, uh, uh,
Pam anonymous was doing,
knew that he was trying to
flank them on the right side.
And so this,
they wanted to take steps to
prevent being flanked on that side.
And so they did something which they
tried to do at the battle of [inaudible],
but it didn't happen for them.
They pull troops out from
the center of their line,
sent them around behind the
Phalanx and put them out.
They hoped on the right wing to
prevent exactly that kind of an event.
But to prevent this as the feed bins
from or the be oceans from charging that
empty spot until it was filled,
they sent their cavalry
upfront to shield them,
not only to shield them, but
in effect to, to hide them.
Certainly the cavalry's being out there
would have kicked up a lot of dust and
uh, they could have hoped that the
demons wouldn't know what was going on.
So that was the theory.
What is a fact is that the oceans,
ocean fact cavalry and the
Spartan Cavalry clashed.
And as I think, again, the bookies, if
this happened, would've predicted, um,
the feed bins defeated the upheld nations
to Siemens had a superior calvary.
Uh, it has to do, of course
with the nature of their land,
which is better for horses
then, uh, most of Greek country.
And so they drove the cavalry back into
the Spartan Phalanx helping to create
confusion and to break ranks
and all that kind of stuff.
But the real payoff,
the real victory in the battle was won
where Pam and on this hoped it would be
on his left flank on
the Spartan right flank.
I don't think it's an
accident that the Phalanx,
the Phalanx came swiftly to the place
where the spartan king was located,
clean Han Broadus and killed him.
And if you look at Greek battles
throughout all of their history,
killing the general in command is a
really good idea because when you do that,
you usually win. If you've got
numbers, uh, Curtis on that,
or just got a general idea of,
of how,
how often that is a decisive
or important element.
It's very frequent, isn't it? When
you kill the general, you'll win.
Curtis knows more about military
history and the Greek world. Anybody.
So I have to consultant.
Um,
so, uh, that thing, the
case, the Spartans fought
bravely and strongly around
the body of their king,
but that only led more than to be killed.
And before very long,
the Spartan Phalanx broke and ran and
the thi bins to be oceans had one,
a clear cut,
unmistakable,
blatant victory in an normal
hoplite battle on a normal field.
And this was the shock felt round.
The Greek world that this had happened,
just changed everything.
There were only,
here's an interesting fact that tells
you something else that's important about
what's going on in the Greek world.
There were only perhaps 700 Sparty eights
in the whole battle and of these 400
were killed. That's the
think about that. I mean,
that's devastating in so many ways.
Um, and it had this all kinds
of effects. It, we shall see.
It immediately shook,
uh,
the control of the Spartans
even over the Peloponnesus. Uh,
it made people think the Spartans were
vulnerable and that they might've come to
the end of the line.
But another interesting
contrary consequence was
that suddenly Sparta wasn't
scary,
but thieves was very scary.
And the Athenians who had already come to,
uh,
be nervous about the Thebans.
You notice I haven't mentioned that
they were, had been the allies of feeds.
They were not at the battle of blue truck.
And as a matter of fact,
they were clearly working with the
Spartans already to check Steven power and
even expansion before the battle of Luke
trip. They stay where they stay neutral.
They didn't show up at the battle at all,
but it tells you a very important
change in the scene, uh, in the,
in the Greek world at this time.
So I think it's safe to say the battle
of Luke Tra put an end to spartan
supremacy.
This apartment had Germany is over.
And now the question that awaits
increases what happens next?
I think in the normal course of events,
prior to the buildup of this new themes,
uh, there would have been a division
of power between the states.
The Athenians would have used some muscle,
the themes would have used some muscle.
Uh,
some lesser states would have
emerged in the vacuum created by the,
the destruction of pavement up spartan
power. But that would have been that.
However,
given all that had happened in the Osha
and the kind of leadership that existed
in Thebes, um, something
amazing then happen.
The feed bins decided to put an end to
spartan power forever and took a number
of measures to bring that about.
Just the defeat of Luke tre meant the
disintegration of the Peloponnesian
League,
a number of states,
obviously it took advantage of Sparta
as weakness to just pull out and get out
from under Spartan control.
And then in the year three 70,
the theme wins,
put together a tremendous army
and,
uh,
ultimately marched into the Peloponnesus
to do what they were going to do.
One of the things that happen
reflecting the collapse of the Spartan,
uh,
a Gemini in the Peloponnesus was that the
towns in the region of Arcadia,
the mountain,
this region to the north of the Sparta,
put themselves together in the
form of the Arcadian League.
And it is,
I mentioned this to you earlier,
I believe it is one of the first federal
leagues of a kind from the one we've
seen up to now.
There is no hegemony will state,
it is not some big state and it's friends
which even the B Ocean League is still
in that category.
It is in fact a collection of states
that are extensively equal and this is
entirely voluntary.
They are coming together,
these Arcadian states in order to
protect themselves and to pursue their
interests against the many troubles
they've had over the years.
And uh,
the question always is then there's,
this is a both the evidence
of what I'm saying,
that it was a new kind of a league and
it reveals the fact that there was no
state that was sufficiently
superior to the others.
That to make it obvious that the capital,
so to speak of this new
confederation would be that state.
They built a brand new city.
It was called,
I love it.
Megalopolis that means it ran
from Washington to Boston.
No, I'm sorry. It meant it meant,
of course it means big
polis, big city, big state,
whatever you want.
Uh,
but it was the place where the a
league counsel met State Center,
their representatives to it.
Their business was done there.
And it's really quite
an interesting event,
especially as you look ahead
in the history of Greason.
And as I told you last time,
that kind of thing had a
remarkable influence on the
thinking of the shapers of
the American constitution.
You Athenians attitude towards this.
We think about all this long
rivalry between Sparta and
Athens that had resulted
in such terrible wars.
It just goes to show you,
what was it, a palmist in the
19th century British statesmen,
I think he wants said Britain has
no permanent friends or enemies,
only permanent interests.
And I think what, whether that was true
or Britain or not at the time, I think,
and we should always realize that that
is true of the way states operate in an
international system.
It is not that they don't
have inclinations and
longstanding friendships do have
some impact and longstanding
enmities have a greater impact.
And yet anything can happen.
I mean just to get some sense of that.
Uh,
who would have believed that,
uh,
in the 1930s that Great Britain and
France would join with Joseph Stalin's
Soviet Union for any purpose,
whatever,
since they,
especially the British had been interested
in putting an end to that regime from
the moment that it was invented and that
Winston Churchill would be the greatest
advocate of this alliance with
styling Winston Churchill,
who had been the leading figure in having
an invasion of Russia in 19 2021 in
order to bring down the Bolshevik
regime and what Churchill, his answer,
I think to the question of
why you're doing this, uh,
tells you a lot about this
general point I'm trying to make.
I'm not going to get this exactly right.
I don't have Churchill's gift and my
memory is fading. But, uh, and he said,
if, you know, why are you
joining up with stolen? You know,
you've been denouncing him forever.
He said, he said, if the devil,
no, I'm sorry. If Hitler invaded hill,
at the very least,
I would want to say a few kind words
about the devil in the House of Commons.
That ought to tell you something about
the permanence of these kinds of thing.
Interests are what matter.
And He,
this Athenian interests had changed.
Thebes was becoming a challenge to the
Athenian growth and influence and power
and they did not want the Thebans now
to destroy Sparta has control of the
Peloponnesus and replace it
with a Thevenin control of
the Peloponnesus and that
accounts both full white,
uh,
Athens is not helping the Thebans but
also in fact intriguing with states in the
Peloponnesus to try to stand up to
the feed bins rather than to do what,
what might seem obvious.
Now the Thebans we're continue, I'm, I'll,
I'll come back to their invasion just
a moment. They were continuing to grow.
They were gaining allies in,
uh,
central Greece forces.
He totally IA at cornea low.
Chris, you'll be here again,
I'm going to be teaching you general
truths about international relations that
are, don't seem to be a part
of the ordinary education.
And that is power.
Has a fantastically attractive quality
when a state is suddenly enormously
powerful. You know, I think the
political scientists rules, uh, I,
and I admit that what I just said has
been known and said by many of them many
times. But the favorite thing is if
there's a great power, what happens next?
What happens is all the other states get
together and join up to two to control
that power to which the answer
is sometimes a lot of times,
and that they have another term
to consider the alternative,
which they called Bandwagon bandwagoning
and that is states are attracted by
that power. Want to get on the right side
of that power, join up with that power.
And that's what happened here,
where suddenly
the theme and power in that area that
became seem so strong that you wanted to
be on that side. I'm just in this
terrible and that analogizing mood today.
So please forgive me.
But,
but lest you think the study of
ancient history is not relevant to your
understanding of the world today,
and I know none of you would
be so foolish as to think that.
Let me just point out, just look
what's happening in the Middle East,
and I'll say it before it's common wisdom
so that you will see how smart I am,
Syria, which has been nothing
but trouble for our side. Uh,
all this time all of a sudden seems
to be behaving in a different way.
And even the United States government
says that the Syrian seemed not to be
feeding more al Qaeda people
across the border into Iraq.
Why is that? What have they
found? Religion? Oh, I guess
they had religion already,
but um,
um,
the answer is because suddenly the
American forces are kicking hell out of
everybody and Iraq and suddenly there's
a powerful American army sitting there,
which is right next door to Iran, to
Syria. It's also right next door we run.
We should have interesting
consequences to, um,
the result is that the Syrians are
suddenly talking very differently.
Now that doesn't mean that there'll be
a permanent change that will depend upon
realities, but it's, I, you need to,
you get fed so much gunk
in a different direction.
The most important single element
in international relations,
not the only one by any means,
but the most important one is power and
the perception of where the power is and
the perception of whether that
power is growing or shrinking.
Nothing is as important as that.
Everything else contributes,
but it doesn't have that central role.
Well that's the situation that the feed
bins have created with their victory.
And so they are expanding
all over the place.
They are even Stevens with
great land Lubbers. They are,
they're even building a navy.
They are moving out into the Aegean Sea.
And uh,
that's one of the things that has
created this nervousness in Athens and
explains the Athenian behavior.
Now comes this great invasion in the,
over the year three 73 69,
the total force of hoplites in the
army put together by [inaudible].
This is reported to be 40,000.
Now there's just not a
number like that, uh, in,
in the whole fifth century
basically or anytime before this.
It's just an amazing army.
And we are told there were some 30,000
others on the campaign who were not
hoplites.
Maybe many of them weren't even fighters,
but a lot of them would have been cavalry,
light armed infantry and so on.
But in any case here,
a 70,000 people,
meaning no good to the Spartans pouring
into the Peloponnesus in that year,
it is the largest military
force reported in Greek history.
The leading the men in charge of these
two extraordinary men at feminine does
and Palapa Das who repeatedly had
proved themselves, by the way,
it was Palapa Das who won that
victory in three 75 at to Gyra.
Remember that with the 300.
So he has that great victory on his
record and feminine does of course is the
architect of the victory at Luke Tra.
And uh,
they just are amazing and remarkable
people. If you read some of those,
uh,
we,
we do not have a blue chalk
biography of APAM anonymous,
although he does give us a Palapa at us.
We're happy about that.
But the owl before I got through,
I will try to remedy that as I tried to
do in the case of THRASS of Boulez by
bringing to your attention how
great was the reputation of Epam.
Anon does in the Greek world.
Maybe I should just say a
word about him now. He, um,
he is reputed to have been
a person of great intellect.
Apparently he was a philosopher and a
took that seriously and was respect with
regard with respect by others,
uh,
of that elk in that world.
And uh, of course he looks,
it looks very much as though he is
a man of political convictions
of such a kindness,
almost a suggest political theory.
I mean,
he seems to have been committed really
to the idea of democracy as a good thing
in itself. On this latter point, we
just don't have very much evidence.
No nothing that he said. Uh,
but we do have what he did,
which squares perfectly with what we
are talking about. It would be, I mean,
it breaks my heart there.
These lives that Plutarch did not right.
What I would give for a life of Christ,
the knees by Plutarch and
similarly of EPAM anonymous.
Uh, and I'm amazed, I don't know who
knows why blue tarp did what he did,
but in any case,
it would be really fascinating in his
case because of the complicated nature of
his mind and his life.
But there he is along with Palapas
leading this armed force in there.
They move down into Laconia,
the home territory of the Spartans.
Now the Spartans are forced to huddle
in their city and to try to resist
anything that comes at them.
They cannot go out to fight these
people invading their homeland.
Their fucking homeland has never
been invaded in anybody's memory.
This is out of the question. Nothing
like this would have been possible.
And here they are just
hiding in their city,
not even a walled city because it was part
of their pride. They don't need walls.
They have an army. Nobody can come
in there and attack their city.
And there they are.
And what does a Pam Anon does do?
He does not go after them in that city
because probably he has a one reason
would have been fighting in the city.
You know,
urban warfare is always difficult and
costly and nobody until lately is really
good at it. Uh, I mean if,
I don't know how much you've paid
attention to what's going on in Iraq these
days in the so called
surge, but when you, if you,
if you study it as a military problem
and then you see how they dealt with that
military problem,
it is one of the really most brilliant
things I have ever seen because it would
be successful in this, in, in
the war I'm talking about now,
requires not only shrewd use of
military forces for military purposes,
but it has to be integrated with constant
political negotiation and conversation
with the natives,
which has to be associated also with
certain economic conditions being brought
about. So that the, uh,
the people who are, uh,
might be on the other side can be on
your side and then you can have them work
for you.
Uh,
and I've only touched on the beginning
of all the complexity of that. So,
but in any case, which until
that, until until that happened,
there are very few cases
of really successful urban
warfare without a tremendous
cost. Well, of course, before they
figured out what to do in Iraq,
they had some tremendous
costs of not figuring it out.
But what I'm getting at is, yes, I'm sure
that if a patent on this and wanted to,
he would have, uh, been able to
defeat the Spartans in their city,
but he would have paid a great price.
Now,
there's perhaps another consideration,
uh, what he, what that, let
me, before I come to that,
let me just tell you that what the,
but apartment houses did his bypass
the city ravage what the countryside,
where ever he founded,
doing as much harm as he possibly could.
And even as this was happening and was
obviously reported back to the Spartans,
the Spartans did not come out to fight.
Now here.
Here's where I think once again,
Victor Hansen's,
a splendid imagination,
uh,
comes into the picture in what I find
to be a very persuasive explanation of
what's going on.
And he'd makes this explanation based
on an analogy he draws with the army of
General Sherman during the American civil
war when Sherman's famous march to the
sea or is march through Georgia when there
is a confederate army to the north of
where he goes,
but he doesn't seek them out.
He goes marching towards
where he wants to get to,
doing as much damage as he possibly can,
destroying the food,
the crops,
animals,
uh,
everything he had burning down houses
being as nasty and unpleasant as he can
be. Uh, why is the question,
will he be nasty, unpleasant
fellow? Not really. He, we,
we do know a lot about what
Sherman thought he was doing
cause he wrote about it.
Sherman apparently hated
this southern slave.
Ocracy he wasn't satisfied with defeating
the south as many a northerner was and
then sort of letting it be what it had
been before or perhaps destroying slavery
itself and leaving everything else.
Pretty much as it had been.
He seems to have thought this
was a terrible wicked society.
And if it wasn't to go
back to its old bad ways,
it not only had to be defeated,
it had to be humiliated.
Part of his,
his view,
part of the success of the south was in
building up what he would've thought of
as a myth of their
aristocratic superiority,
which made slave holding appropriate
because the people who were superior were
ruling over people who were inferior
and they deserved it because they were
better fighters than anybody else.
Everybody a thought at
the beginning of the war,
certainly that the south had a better
military tradition and that they were
better soldiers and I think they were,
uh,
and that they were courageous.
Being a great military man means being
courageous and all of that justify the
system and provided the pride that
made it possible to work well.
Sherman wanted to show it wasn't so,
and here they were burning down houses
and Barns and food and the women folk
having to stand there and watch it.
And where was the confederate army?
He didn't come down to challenge them
and he felt in the process he was
destroying the myth that was more potent.
Well,
I think he's so handsome. Certainly has
that right when he talks about Sherman,
and it's very attractive to
think that may be Pam Anon.
This was after the same thing.
Here were the Spartans
cowering in their city.
It would be said while a Pam and on
this was doing as he liked with the
Peloponnesus.
There would never again be a time where
people would accept the story that the
Spartans with a great fighter is the great
heroes, et Cetera, et Cetera, et cetera.
In any case, that's what
he did. And then it wasn't.
I think all of this is assisted by some
of the things he did and some of the
things that he actually said.
He went to Macedonia.
And indeed he went to the place where
the Mycenaeans had withdrawn for security
and in their rebellions up there,
uh,
and he established or reestablished
a city called Mess Sini.
It was powerfully fortify.
There was up on a mountain.
It was a place where you
could really defend it.
And it became the capital of Miscellanea,
which would now be a Freeman seenia
in which the former [inaudible],
the former slaves of the spartan state,
would now rule their own country
as they had not done for centuries.
And it was a liberation and it was,
that was the language that
Apam Anon is used of it.
It had the marvelous psychological
effects that I'm speaking of.
And also a very practical one here was
a fortress on the flank of the Spartans,
which was controlled by people
who hated the Spartans bitterly.
And that would guarantee that the Spartans
would not likely gain control of the
western Peloponnesus.
Again, if you add to that,
that the Arcadians had suffered plenty
from the Spartans and we're unwilling to
allow the Spartans to rise again,
and there was megalopolis
a walled powerful city that
would see to it that the
Spartans would never likely be able to
make their way into control of central
and northern Peloponnesus again.
And so all of this combination of
power and the strategic use of power,
uh,
along with this psychological
warfare that was involved,
brought about the, uh,
permanent check on Sparta,
Sparta. Amazingly enough, when emerged
from this still an independent city,
still somehow taken seriously by others,
but never again in the
position of threatening the
security of a other stakes.
Now, some of what was happening, uh,
began to create a counter
force as it always does.
Here was this blatantly democratic
force that had been unleashed in the
Peloponnesus, most of which had
always been oligarchic. So in Arcadia,
there began to be a revival
of oligarchic activity.
People who wanted to overthrow the
regime that was being established and to
restore oligarchic governments,
which would of course naturally
be friendly to Sparta.
And some of these oligarchs in
Arcadia began to assist the Spartans.
We know the Spartans were finished,
but they didn't know it.
The Greeks at the time didn't know it.
So that I'm,
I'm just touching on the high points here.
In three 62 by now,
I should report that Palapa Diaz was dead.
He had died fighting
incessantly against a, uh, uh,
an autocrat there by the name of
Jason from the city of Fareye. Uh,
who about it,
and we don't know a lot except to say
you've got to be very powerful indeed,
and was pretty soon challenging both
thieves on the land and also challenging
Athens to some degree at sea. Uh, and he,
who knows how much trouble he would have
made had he not died before he could do
so. But apartment, sorry. Palapa does
died fighting in a battle against, uh,
uh, Jason, I think it was
three 64. So in three 62,
when the Thebans again put together a
forced to invade the Peloponnesus to put
down those forces that were
working against his settlement,
it was only EPAM. Anon
does, who was in charge
apparently in the battle of [inaudible].
This is the second battle of Maton Nia,
the first took place in the Peloponnesian
war and four 18 but this one in three
62, apparently, uh,
upenn monotonous use some of the very
same tactics that had been successful in
the, uh, in the battle that look,
Trump and the thi bins won
the battle of lecture, uh,
of, uh, uh, man Tinea, however,
at Pamet on vis was
killed in the fighting.
And it turned out that that was
more important than anything else.
W with both Palapa das and Epam,
Anon does gone.
Thebes never again shows that kind of
special quality that brought it swiftly to
power and will swiftly bring it down.
Although we,
as we look at the world in three 62,
we should realize that Thebes
remains a very formidable power.
And the Greeks, again, I want to more new,
don't know that seems isn't going to
come back and with two new leaders or 10
new leaders or one or whatever,
and become the same kind of a
menace that it had been before.
But looking back,
we can see that that was the outcome.
So, uh, this evening has won the victory,
but in effect they really lost the war
because that was the end of their special
quality.
CICERO writing about this year,
centuries later called Epam Pamet on desk,
the foremost man of Greece,
there is an inscription or there
wasn't an inscription on it,
[inaudible] statue that was
erected on his death at Thebes.
And it is as though he was speaking,
it must have been taken somehow,
uh,
from something he said or wrote.
Here's what he said by my plans was
Sparta Shorn of her glory and Holy Miss
Seenia had last received back her
children by the weapons of Thebes was miss
seenia fortified and all Greece
became independent and free.
Now,
of course,
the claim that everybody was seeking
independence for the Greeks out tonal.
Mia is an old stale,
uh,
one that never really worked.
This is the first time that I am aware.
No, I should, that's not true.
The Spartans entered the Peloponnesian
war claiming that they were fighting to
free the Greeks,
but of course they immediately began in
slaving as many of them as they could
when they won the war. But
a Pam and don says, well,
we did this, we accomplish this. And
at the end of the day, the Greeks, the,
the, uh, all of Greece was free.
He claimed sure it wasn't perfectly true,
but there was a lot in it.
And, uh, that's what he was proud of.
That's what he thought he was doing.
I think that's the important
point about that quotation.
It tells us what he would have wanted,
has indeed,
and has worked out that way
to come down as his legacy.
What did a Honda did he say he
increased the power of Thebes tenfold?
He made Thebes name ringing the
Valhalla. He never heard of Valhalla, um,
in the Valhalla of heroes
throughout history. Uh,
that's not what he wanted to have said.
What he wanted it to have said was,
I restored the Mycenaeans to their land.
I restored them to safety.
I gave them freedom.
I left Greece free and independent
Xenophon writing.
After his description of the battle
of Manton, it says the following,
and these are the last words in his
[inaudible] and his history of Greek
affairs.
In his time since nearly all the people
of Greece have come together or had come
together and form themselves
in opposing lines,
there was no one who did not suppose
that if a battle were fought,
those who proved victorious
would be the rulers.
And those who were defeated would be
their subjects while each side claimed to
be victorious.
Neither was found to be any better
off than before the battle took place.
But there was even more confusion and
disorder in Greece after the battle than
before. So here's a case for the, um,
the unimportance of warfare.
You might say for those people
that want to make that case,
that hair was all this fighting here are
all the dead. And at the end of the day,
nothing had been settled.
That is often the case in war,
although it might be said that something
pretty serious had been settled by the
campaigns that the feed bins had fought
before the battle of Manson, Nia.
And at before the battle of math and the
and that Greece will never be the same
again because of the fighting
that had taken place before.
But as we look forward,
not backwards,
it's worth noticing that that the
years of competition for had Gemini,
which go back,
you know,
at least to the days after the Persian
wars had left Greece weakened and divided
and therefore open for exploitation
and even conquest by a new threat from
outside the system,
which was not even dreamed of by the
Greeks as a menace in three 62 at the bat
and Love Man Antonia.
And there's something to be learned in,
in there too. I mean if you had
taken a poll of the Greeks and said,
where are the dangers to us now?
What problems do we have?
What they would have been talking about
the traditional conflicts between the
Greek city states.
No one I think with have used the word
Macedonia as part of anything that looked
scary.
And of course nobody would have uttered
the name Phillip Because Phillip wasn't
even king of Macedonia yet.
And yet within a few years,
Phillip would be the king of Macedonia,
and within a couple of three decades,
it would suddenly be a
real menace from the north.
That would be very threatening,
and we'll take a look at that next time.